StuH was nothing actually it's not Star
Wars it's rook one it'd be like rogue
why cuz it's rogue one or Star Wars or
different to everyone every time a new
trailer for rogue one a Star Wars story
and this trailer delves a little more to
jennarose father played by Mads
Mikkelsen and it happens exactly how you
would think it's like cinema 101 if you
want to show the past you show it and
then when the scene ends you have the
main character wake up in the
presidential what a nightmare however
this is important because it shows how
the rebellion kind of gets wrapped up
with jyn erso and why they want her help
and why they work together it's not just
like the rebellion comes to this girl is
just like you got Moxie kid you got
moxie used to does you'll be all right
now they're like your father had a big
hand in creating the scariest death
weapon ever seen in 1977 I think we can
help each other out
yeah he's the huge hand in creating the
Death Star which had to be some
motivation right what are they
threatened him with Lando Calrissian I
kind of understand where Darth Vader's
like hey hand over Han Solo otherwise
we're gonna do horrible to everyone
who lives here what do they say to him
though just like I will create a weapon
that can blow up planets and genocide
aliy wipe out civilizations otherwise
what you're gonna genocide only
wipe out other civilization what's
what's the escalation they're basically
jyn erso is looking for her father in
this movie she's like we need to find
him which makes me question it's like I
mean obviously this guy was forced to do
this thing but was he always for us I
mean it's been years
so was he indoctrinated by them like is
he like you know I gotta say why you
need a death weapon to control the
galaxy so let's just go ahead and do
that so when she finds him is she gonna
be disappointed where he's like yeah it
started out hostile but it's not now I
agree with them these are the questions
I asked in trailers and that's what
trailers are fun because you get to ask
questions you do not know the answers do
the speculation phase of a movie's
release is arguably the funnest part of
the movie's release looks like Jin
orso's doing them pep talks they're like
they've been through so much she's
the glue now holding the rebellion
together she's like we have hope
rebellions are built on hope they're all
like Church still looking forward to
seeing this dude man I want this dude so
good i pre-order his hot toy the moment
I walk out of the movie theater like
when he's talking to Vader and he's like
we are gonna I'm paraphrasing
but I'm pretty sure that's what he meant
when he was talking to the Lord helmet
Vader's not in this much which is great
I didn't want to see a lot of it I don't
want to see
Fator whip out his lightsaber and kick
some ass in the trailer I don't want
that if that's going to happen you saved
that for the movie but the one clear
shot we get evader he is walking in a
room he's pissed it looks best anyway
he's just walking with conviction he's
walking in like this is some so
rogue one definitely looks like a darker
grittier thing you look at all the tech
in rogue one it's tech that we've seen
in a Star Wars saga it just looks like
it's a darker shittier time let's just
that hologram of the Death Star even in
a modern movie like the force awakens
the Holograms they had of the Death Star
and Starkiller base looked cleaner than
this dude here in a war movie I like me
some gritty dirty aesthetics but really
honestly when you watch this trailer
through the scope of these people are
probably going to die I'm taking a guess
here I'm just saying the fact that we
don't see them in the original Star Wars
trilogy means they probably died just
I'm waiting for that tragic hold the
line moment I want to see how they do
that it still looks awesome it looks
like the war movie set in the Star Wars
saga that we were promised so long ago
bye guys so the new trailer the third
trailer for Star Wars rogue one or rogue
one the Star Wars story have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]